في خليج المكسيك البحر هنا بمثابه الجنه
لعشاق صيد الاسماك هذا الخليج يضخ من
الاسماك والجمبري والمحار سنويا اكثر من
جنوب ووسط المحيط الاطلسي
سياحه صيد الاسماك هنا منتشره للغايه
شواطئ هذه القريه الصغيره التي تسمى بونتا
الينا بسكانها الذين لا يتجاوز عددهم 500
نسمه هي وجهه مفضله لمحبي الصيد بواسطه
الصنانير
هنا نزول تيزيانو ثماني غرف للضيوف في
انتظار الصيادين الذين يتوافدون عليه
ليصبح نقطه انطلاقهم الى مياه الخليج
للاستمتاع بالصيف
[موسيقى]
التقاط هذه الاسماك الاربع المميزه في
الخليج اصبح بمثابه الحصول على الجائزه
الكبرى انه حلم لجميع صيادي الاسماك
بالصنانير ولذلك فانهم لن يدخروا جهدا
لتحقيق ذلك
[موسيقى]
الزاهره لهذه المجموعه الصغيره التي تنطلق
باكملها للوصول الى مواقع الصيد المختلفه
وهي ايضا صياده ماهر لكن دوره زيان اليوم
ومرافقه الزبائن من الصيادين
[موسيقى]
هم مساعدون لا غنى عنهم ينصحون الصيادين
ويطمئنونهم لكنهم وقبل كل شيء يعرفون
البحر والاسماك اكثر من اي شخص اخر
بعد عده سنوات من البحث حول العالم وضعها
حقائبهما المليئه بالصنانير في بونتا
الينا صهاري على خدمه عشاق الصيد هنا
[موسيقى]
شاركونا ارائكم هل ترغبون في تجربه صيد
كهذه على شواطئ المكسيك
[موسيقى]